[Musique]
amis
euh comment allez-vous juste comme
euh la saison n'est pas finie euh non
euh ouais je vais bien mais ouais les
joueurs commencent maintenant
c'est un peu occupé nous avons eu un très dur
les joueurs de l'année qui arrivent les
joueurs qui partent donc ouais ça a été une
saison vraiment difficile mais ouais nous devons être prêts
pour les séries éliminatoires maintenant d'
accord euh première chose
euh on s'appelle ander
ce qui signifie green span alors
demandons euh ta quelle est ta taille
euh poids et  gagner de l'envergure je ne sais pas si
vous le savez mais
voulez-vous que je dise alors en pieds ou en
centimètres
euh vous pouvez dire que les centimètres sont plus faciles
peut-être des
centimètres et euh ma longueur
je suis 2 8 donc 208 centimètres
mon envergure est de 2 216  216
et ouais voyons comme ça d'accord et
euh le poids le poids euh je suis autour de
93 94 kilos d'accord donc c'est autour ouais
qu'est-ce que c'est 210 livres
je pense euh je vais je vais juste euh
diriez-vous 94 94  ouais
c'est deux deux ou cinq euh ouais deux ou cinq
ouais juste là
ouais c'est une question piège mais tu as  n'importe quel
indice sur la taille de vos mains
parce que c'est quelque chose que les gens
vont demander ouais non je n'en ai
pas et je ne sais pas j'ai je n'ai pas
une très grosse tête je regarde maintenant
mais je ne '  t ont vraiment
nous avons un tas de gars c'est l'une
des premières questions qu'ils ont posées comme je
serais là
ouais oh d'accord je n'ai jamais entendu la question
avant euh
ouais si jamais tu vas à la moissonneuse-batteuse
tu auras la réponse
ouais d'accord d'accord  est ce que tu vas mesurer
aller a l'inde combiner
j'attend euh peut etre mon agent en
sait plus mais euh je n'ai pas encore d'
invitation car c'est jolie inviter
mais ouais on verra sinon j'ai
juste euh pratique avec les equipes de la nba en
début juillet
ils sont alignés mais ouais on
attend la moissonneuse
car ils veulent que je me concentre sur la
saison en ce moment et je veux ça aussi je
ne veux pas trop en savoir encore on
verra après les playoffs mais  que va-
t-il se passer,
ne vous inquiétez pas, votre agence est
assez forte, alors
oui, c'est sûr que je  pensez à beaucoup de
relations dont vous avez besoin de plus à ce sujet,
bien sûr ouais quelle est l'agence euh roma
euh vassar manster ouais westerman ouais
ouais euh alors vous avez dit entre six neuf et
six
dix euh nous avons défini votre poids mais euh qui êtes-
vous parce que
nous vous connaissons  euh il y a quelques années,
vous avez joué avec la belgique dans les championnats de la jeunesse de la fiba
, mais
euh aussi toute personne suivant le
repêchage de la nba votre nom n'était pas
sur la liste restreinte avant la
saison alors pouvez-vous
simplement expliquer qui vous êtes où  tu es
d'où tu as grandi
je pense que je vais commencer depuis le
début euh
ouais donc j'ai commencé quand j'étais jeune euh
avec enter gian donc j'ai joué toute ma
carrière
à anvers je sors vraiment du
eu euh
je'  m je suis c'est ma troisième année pro maintenant
première année je n'ai pas beaucoup joué
comme 11 12 mec euh
il y a un an j'étais euh de retour au
meneur euh de luca rupnik
nous avons aussi joué bcl champions league
euh j'en ai eu  quelques minutes là-bas mais j'étais un
gars vraiment maigre encadré
pas assez fort t  o joue encore à ce
niveau mais je pense que l'été quand
kovit est arrivé
j'ai vraiment construit ma force euh
je suis devenu plus fort parce que je suis passé de 70
kilos
70 ouais à 90 91 92
maintenant j'ai 93 mais ouais j'ai beaucoup travaillé  donc je
pense que c'est pourquoi
euh je me suis amélioré et c'était une
chose vraiment importante
pour moi mon euh mon profil d'
accord euh est ta famille
dans le basket-ball ou est-ce que ta mère
ou ton père
jouait professionnellement euh je veux dire
ma famille ils jouent toujours au basket  à
un niveau bas pas à un niveau élevé spécial
euh je pense que je suis le premier qui
joue vraiment au basket professionnel
qui joue vraiment à un niveau professionnel alors
oui j'essaie d'en tirer le meilleur
parti et euh fais de mon mieux
chaque  jour pour aller de plus en plus haut vers qui
allez-vous quand
vous avez besoin d'un conseil je ne sais pas
sur la vie ou quoi que ce soit d'autre euh
un conseil j'essaie d'ouais j'essaie de
tendre la main à deux coéquipiers qui jouaient euh
quand je jouais quand  je jouais en
arrière-cour j'étais comme aller à
luca rupnic j'en avais  parler avec
luka doncic au téléphone c'était vraiment
spécial parce qu'il m'a donné des conseils
que je
peux vraiment utiliser maintenant parce que c'est le meilleur ami
de luca rupnik
et euh la première fois que nous sommes allés sur le
jeu de la route, ils faisaient face et euh
lui parlaient  était vraiment spécial alors
oui je pense que luca rupnik m'a beaucoup aidé
à voir le match et oui si j'ai
besoin de conseils je vais voir l'entraîneur ou
quoi que
ce soit donc rien de vraiment spécial d'accord
vous avez vous avez joué vous l'avez dit vous
t'as joué
toute ta vie euh dans l'injuste
ouais euh comment tu te sens euh
toi la question te sera
surement posée
euh pourquoi pourquoi n'es-tu pas allé
dans une équipe plus exposée euh nous on a tellement
kiffé l'a fait  l'année dernière tu y es allé
ça s'est bien passé tu n'avais pas envie
pourquoi tu as fait ça
ouais j'avais de bonnes offres mais pour moi c'était
vraiment important de
ne pas jouer pour une grande équipe mais d'avoir beaucoup
d'expérience de
jeu  la raison aussi est ouais nous avons joué à la
coupe de l'euro alors d'
accord c'était peut-être un peu  trop haut
pour notre niveau d'équipe
mais je pense que j'ai eu une bonne expérience il est
né aussi ouais
j'avais une offre de deuxième équipe de barcelone la
plupart des joueurs la
prendront et y iront parce que jouer
sous barcelone tout le
monde le veut mais pour moi c'était
important de grandir  en tant que joueur
pour grandir en tant que personne et je pense que j'ai fait
le bon choix
donc je veux dire que c'est l'excuse c'est
si vous le regardez comme la façon dont cela s'est passé
pendant la saison,
vous avez eu une saison de coupe d'euro assez solide
comme personnellement je veux dire
alors ouais  le detroit le choix est
intéressant car tu as joué
contre euh des équipes russes tu joues
contre euh bologne tu comptes avoir des
équipes solides donc c'est
le meilleur moyen d'évoluer tu restes chez toi
il y a un bon compromis alors pourquoi aller
ailleurs
si tu peux avoir ta coupe  à la maison ouais
ils ont fini
donc c'était une grande chose pour moi aussi ouais si
tu peux jouer contre ces équipes je pense que
c'est vraiment trop c'est vraiment une
expérience
et c'était bien pour moi pas de manque de respect mais ça
aurait été  fr comme tu sais
défi fiba ou quelque chose aurait
été différent non ouais
c'est ouais c'est de l'exposition solide
c'est vrai mais les équipes de la nba vont
surement te demander
euh et euh se demander
si tu es prêt à t'éloigner de ton
cocon parce que
toi tu vas  oui tu as toujours été
là quelle est ta réponse
à cette question je veux dire je suis vraiment
parce que je parle avec beaucoup de gars qui
viennent à l'étranger
quand ils viennent ici de l'état
parce que nous avons deux nouveaux gars
une recrue et un gars qui est venu  tout droit
sorti de julie
et c'était vraiment difficile pour eux d'ouais
ils n'ont pas de
famille ici ils sont seuls et j'essaie
vraiment euh de les
laisser se sentir bien alors je pense que
je pense que j'ai vraiment grandi beaucoup
je vraiment je pense que je  Je suis prêt à partir à l'
étranger parce que je pense que
je prends vraiment soin de
ces gars pour qu'ils se
sentent bien, donc je pense que je peux le faire pour
moi aussi d'
accord, parlons du jeu dont
nous avons parlé euh  la coupe de l'euro
euh tu as joué euh en premier
quel joueur est  vous à vous personnellement
comment vous sentez-vous que pensez-vous est votre
meilleur rôle dans une équipe
je veux dire ma position préférée est un deux
gardes comme les deux
gardes de tir euh parce que j'aime jouer
avec le ballon dans mes mains donc
meneur de jeu secondaire  est toujours un bon
endroit pour moi
mais aussi un point fort est que je peux
aussi jouer oh
je ne peux pas jouer avec le ballon donc je pense que
c'est un bon point une bonne chose dans mon
euh mon profil dans lequel je peux jouer avec le
ballon  mes mains mais aussi
jouer au ballon donc je pense que oui, le deux
points est
un endroit parfait pour moi mais aussi le fait
est que je ne peux pas jouer sur l'arbre
peut-être plus tard quand je deviendrai plus fort peut-être
sur les quatre mais
nous verrons pour ça  d'accord, alors
quel est ton ticket pour le repêchage de la nba
qu'est-ce que tu penses comment tu penses comment tu
te vendrais fondamentalement comme en
ce moment si tu dois garder les principales
caractéristiques comme
disons que nous sommes nous sommes le front office et
vous  besoin d'aimer essentiellement vous
vendre vous voyez ce que je veux dire ouais je
sais je sais que je n  J'ai besoin de travailler là-dessus, mais
je pense que je dirais que je suis un premier
joueur très polyvalent et
que je peux faire beaucoup de ce dont l'équipe a
besoin.
Je pense que c'est une chose très importante
que les
équipes peuvent utiliser et que les
autres joueurs sont vraiment à leur place
et je peux euh euh
comme intégrer euh que les
gens n'ont pas à changer mais je ne peux pas
changer facilement
si nous avons deux deux gardes je peux facilement
jouer sur l'arbre pour
que ce soit facile pour l'équipe qui
rend les choses plus faciles
ouais  vous parlez de polyvalence
de ma part, donc c'est assez facile pour moi,
mais
pensez-vous que cette
question directe est simple, mais
pensez-vous que vous pouvez maintenir
ce jeu
à un niveau supérieur avec les différents
types d'
athlétisme euh  devant toi qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'est-
ce que la question oh ouais
je pense vraiment que je peux tenir le
parce qu'avec le niveau auquel je joue je joue avec
tu sais je veux dire
si je joue avec euh des gars qui euh
comme ibuffet c'est si facile de  jouer et
quand quand quand c'était  Dans l'équipe, mes
aides étaient si faciles à lui donner
parce qu'il ne peut pas sauter et qu'il ne peut pas attraper de
passes lentes et
c'est ce qui me manque en ce moment avec le
débutant, il n'aime pas vraiment ça,
donc
je dois changer mon  mes mes passes pour lui
je pense que même dans la ligue ça va être
je pense plus facile même mais ouais nous verrons
euh je ne pense pas euh ils vont
être un grand changement ou quelque chose ouais merci
pour  me rappelant que le nom de
ton coéquipier nous a détruit
il y a quelques semaines il a fait un travail solide contre nous alors
ouais ouais il est gentil euh il est vraiment
je pense qu'il était mon meilleur coéquipier jusqu'à
présent et euh
on a une très bonne relation alors
ouais  nous verrons à l'avenir peut-être que nous nous
réunirons, espérons-le, d'accord, nous,
nous pouvons voir, je veux dire les gens qui regardent la
vidéo, ils peuvent voir
la bande euh nous nous avons sélectionné
dans votre jeu euh commençons par le
tournage
parce que vous avez été touché  beaucoup comment
avez-vous fait euh parce que vous
jouiez beaucoup
au ballon plus tôt mais vous êtes  Je suis
vraiment à l'aise avec la
prise et le tir, alors comment avez-vous travaillé dessus
ouais bien sûr
euh j'aime vraiment jouer en dribble
surtout sur l'arbre parce que mon
milieu de gamme je ne l'utilise pas assez
euh mais ouais le truc était  comme
il y a deux ans,
j'ai vraiment commencé à soulever beaucoup, je
devenais plus fort et
garder mon tir sur la même
chose sur la même piste était
vraiment difficile pour moi, donc
comme l'été dernier, je me suis vraiment
dit ouais je veux parce que nous
nous étions sur le point de jouer à l'euro league je
voulais vraiment
être un bon tireur parce que dans
ma jeunesse j'étais un très bon
tireur
donc je voulais vraiment avoir une bonne saison
même je pense que
j'avais en moyenne 35 je pense que c'est beaucoup trop bas
pour  ce que je peux faire
donc je ne suis pas content de ça mais
ouais je pense que
chaque année s'améliore donc je
continue à m'entraîner
dessus donc j'espère que l'année prochaine ce sera
au-dessus de 30 mais c'est ce que je
veux vraiment  c'est pourquoi je le veux
vraiment c'est ce que je veux vraiment
c'est une répétition  ns tout simplement simple
ou est-ce des
exercices situationnels euh comment travaillez-vous dessus
nah j'essaie d'obtenir autant de
répétitions rouges que possible
même après l'entraînement avant l'entraînement je
pense que c'est
vraiment la seule chose qui
va vous aider euh
je ne '  Je ne pense pas comme euh si plus
tu prends de
coups, meilleur tu es et je pense comme ça alors
je vais continuer à faire ça et nous
verrons je pense que cet été a payé j'ai
pris beaucoup de coups
j'étais beaucoup dans le gymnase  et maintenant,
c'est vraiment important pour moi d'être un
bon maillot parce que c'est aussi très
important pour l'équipe
si nous avons des gars qui peuvent attaquer le
ring avec
force et que vous avez des
tireurs autour, je pense que c'est vraiment
important
mais aussi j'aime vraiment jouer euh
juste sur le dribble euh dans le coup
j'aime vraiment ça aussi donc
j'essaie d'avoir autant de
situations euh plus je peux tirer de
mieux c'est donc c'est ce
que euh c'est ce que nous '  J'importe vraiment ça
pour moi donc
tu es toi  peut soit apporter des points sur les
pull-up pull-up
et le tir direct spot-up shooter spot-up
shooter ou
et tirer des situations ou préféreriez-vous
aller peut-être plus repéré
comme euh
cette saison je prends plus de coups sur la
prise à coup sûr
mais je vraiment  je ne peux pas tirer sur le dribble
euh je veux dire plus d'arbres parce que
j'utilise à peine le milieu de gamme
et c'est la chose que je dois
utiliser beaucoup plus parce que cela me rendra
plus
euh ouais plus dangereux je veux dire
euh mais ouais je ne l'ai pas fait  Je ne l'utilise pas assez cette
saison et si je travaille
plus dessus le tir à mi-portée, ce
sera mieux
pour ma carrière aussi pouvez-vous aller l'un ou l'autre
des deux côtés pour ça
ouais ouais ce n'est pas un problème à
gauche ou à droite  je ne me sens
pas meilleure main aussi en dribble
je ne pense pas que ma droite soit meilleure que ma
gauche donc c'est aussi je préfère aller
avec ma main gauche vers le panier que la
droite quand je  Je suis droitier, donc
je ne sais pas, je ne ressens aucune
différence, d'
accord, nous en reparlerons plus tard.
car pour le dépassement je pense que tu
préfères la
droite euh je n'ai pas passé avec toi
il te reste tant
que ça mais j'ai une question sur
le tir
quand on regarde les mécaniques
on voit que le haut du corps est vraiment
droit
et il y a  absolument aucun problème à
ce sujet,
mais votre corps semble divisé en deux moitiés
et
le bas du corps est moins
équilibré, il semble laissé équilibré
avez-vous l'impression que vous
travaillez dessus ou non je ne
ressens pas vraiment de problèmes mais je sais  parce que euh
nous avons
aussi un bon entraîneur physique et euh
j'ai besoin d'être juste plus j'ai besoin d'être
plus flexible et c'est la plus grande
chose dans
mon truc maintenant d'être plus bas pour baisser
pour baisser mes jambes et euh donc je peux
vraiment être dans l'alimentation et être plus rapide
si vous si vous si si vous ne pouvez pas vous asseoir bas euh
je peux être plus rapide et défendre euh encore
mieux
et c'est la chose en ce moment je ne peux pas
facilement faire des compétences parce que je suis long et
j'ai de longs bras mais
quand je deviens plus flexible et que je
travaille vraiment dessus  t maintenant,
je pense que je peux être un meilleur défenseur
ouais d'accord pour vous, c'est plus une question de
flexibilité que euh ouais mais je pense
que
c'est la plus grande chose ma flexibilité
à coup sûr je suis sûr à 100 de ce
droit c'est intéressant um roma avez-
vous un
question sur le tournage ou pouvons-
nous passer à la partie suivante
[Musique]
la seule chose que j'ai probablement, nous
allons en parler un peu plus
tard, vous savez,
c'est l'équilibre entre la menace que vous
pouvez apporter de l'
extérieur de la capacité  vous devez
créer et distribuer
et le fait que parfois
cela semble un peu déséquilibré, vous
savez le nombre de coups que vous pouvez
prendre de l'extérieur par rapport aux
compétences que vous pouvez avoir et
le fait que vous savez essayer peut-être de
finir  plus de rêve avec qui pourrait
vous amener un peu plus à refriger pour la
ligne vous voyez ce que je veux dire ici juste une
question de oui je pense
que c'est parce que si j'utilise un pick-and-roll
ou quoi que ce soit
je cherche vraiment à passer et je pense que
je  il faut être plus agressif  dans la salle
et je pense que ça viendra
quand je serai plus parce que
j'aime vraiment être j'ai plus d'assistance que j'ai de
points et c'est
pourquoi je cherche plus à passer et à
trouver l'homme au-dessus, puis regarde mon  euh pour
moi
donc je pense que ça viendra le je pense que j'ai
besoin
j'ai juste besoin d'un peu plus de temps et de
confiance et
je pense que cela viendra à coup sûr parce que
fondamentalement, si vous regardez
les chiffres bruts, vous savez qu'il suffit de regarder les
feuilles de statistiques
si vous regardez  en ce moment la façon dont
j'aime comme tout
sur l'écran de moi vos
meilleurs jeux
statistiquement en termes de points et
tout ce que
vous êtes allé à la ligne à peu près une ou
deux exceptions mais par exemple
cubain euh vous marquez 11 vous allez  à la ligne
euh tu vas tu vas à la ligne tu es tu as
besoin de
12 coups donc il y a quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant ici en termes de
peut-être comme vous savez à l'envers concernant l'
équilibre dans le jeu et le genre
de jeu complet que vous voulez  apporter une
belle agressivité juste ouais  encre si
je suis agressif envers la jante, je peux obtenir
beaucoup de lancers
francs mais si je ne suis pas assez agressif
et que je cherche plus à passer, je n'obtiendrai pas
les lancers francs et je pense que
c'est juste un état d'esprit
comment  à propos de la finition euh par
contact
car assez léger pour
ta taille et le nda est évidemment plus
physique
que la ligue belge
je sais que je sais que je dois travailler là-dessus à
coup sûr et euh
je pense que j'ai beaucoup gagné mais je ne le suis pas  fait
encore
j'ai besoin d'avoir mon poids besoin d'être autour
du chasseur je pense
que ce serait un moyen parfait pour moi mais
c'est difficile parce que
j'ai pris près de 20 kilos
en deux ans donc c'était beaucoup et
pour l'année prochaine j'ai vraiment  Je veux aller aux
100 kilos
mais plus je deviens fort, plus
ça va être facile de
finir en contact donc mais je travaille dessus en
ce moment même avec ça
avec ce cadre de corps euh que j'ai en ce moment
mais je pense
à ça  ligue je peux le faire mais pour
la prochaine étape j'ai vraiment besoin d'
améliorer l'emballage euh  qu'est-ce que
c'est naturel est-ce que ça vient
naturellement le passage le
tu es génial euh euh ou travailles-tu
sur une
partie spécifique de celui-ci euh au début euh pas
vraiment je pense que c'est vraiment
la division de base je suppose ouais je pense
c'était
quand j'étais plus jeune je l'avais vraiment
c'est aussi
pour ça qu'en belgique si t'es grand tu joues
normalement sur le cinq et si t'es petit
t'es un meneur
mais c'est ça que j'avais une bonne
vision du court quand j'étais
plus jeune  et c'est pourquoi j'ai toujours
joué au poste de meneur
et puis et je pense que parce que j'ai joué
dès mon plus jeune âge au poste de meneur,
j'ai vraiment eu la vision de savoir où
passer et
je pense que c'est juste une sorte de compétence que je
ne fais pas  Je
n'ai pas besoin de travailler beaucoup là-dessus ou quelque chose comme
ça, donc il y a probablement un entraîneur quelque part
qui s'est rendu compte que pour vous garder sur le
périmètre
euh quand j'avais environ 15
16 ans, l'entraîneur de deuxième
division voulait me mettre sur  l'étage
mais j'avais aussi un entraîneur sur l'und  euh 18 ans
et il voulait me jouer
le deuxième euh ouais sur les deux et euh
quand j'ai eu le
championnat d'europe j'ai eu de
très bons matchs où vous pouvez voir que je
presque
chaque attaque j'utilise un pick and roll et
c'est vraiment  montré que
je ne peux vraiment pas le faire et je pense que
c'était la plus grande opportunité à
venir mais euh
ouais c'était bien de rencontrer un tas de gars intelligents en
fait ouais
bien sûr ouais c'est vrai
pouvez-vous passer avec vos amis de la main gauche
bien sûr pouvez-vous le passer  avec votre main gauche
parce que oh ouais je n'ai pas vu j'ai vu
pas mal de films
euh de vos jeux et je ne me souviens pas de
beaucoup de passes avec votre main gauche
je ne pense pas que je pense vraiment je je
je ne peux pas passer avec la gauche parce que comme je l'ai déjà dit en dribble aussi je
ne sens pas de différence en tir
je le sens c'est sûr mais
en dribble en passant c'est pareil
pour moi si tu veux que je donne en
travers  au coin avec ma gauche
sur ma droite tu vas être exactement la
même passe donc je ne suis pas  en y pensant vraiment,
c'est
plus le moment du jeu quelle main je
peux utiliser le mieux et
peut-être que parfois je prends la mauvaise
décision peut-être mais
oui ce n'est pas vraiment une chose ma
main droite est plus forte que ma gauche à
propos des lectures que vous faites  sur
le pick and roll
avez-vous un modèle euh quelle bande
qui aimez-
vous regarder pour entrer euh
je ne regarde pas vraiment beaucoup les gens mais
un gars comme luca doncic comment il regarde
le tribunal
comment il  voit le terrain ou euh mila le fait toujours
j'ai joué contre lui à coup sûr mais comment il
voit le terrain est super à voir
et là ce sont des gars qui sont vraiment un
exemple pour vous pour moi personnellement
et je pense qu'ils peuvent vous apprendre beaucoup et
si  tu regardes leur jeu ça peut t'aider
mais euh ouais je pense que c'est aussi une chose
que
tu dois avoir c'est ça doit être euh un
talent qui est dans
ce qu'ils peuvent t'apprendre euh
c'est une question difficile mais euh comment
ils donnent les passes
ils sont les premiers  agressif à la jante le
no look passe euh
fr  om mila toujours cette démangeaison, ils sont super
euh ouais des choses comme ça d'
accord
comment gérez-vous euh avec la
pression de la balle
quand la défense devient difficile sur les écrans
quand ils sont durs parce que je
regarde des clips en ce moment alors je '  je suis
intéressé d'avoir votre
analyse oh dur sur la trappe dure euh
ouais c'est que je n'aime pas ça parce que je
dois
faire venir des gars et se montrer
pour faire le triangle
mais euh ouais c'est sûr que ce n'est pas euh la
défense la plus drôle
pour le  le gars qui utilise le
pick-and-roll mais euh
ouais c'est juste comme ou un écran glissant euh
le gars sort pour faire des triangles
juste comme ça c'est pas vraiment
difficile de s'en sortir
mais ouais c'est juste pas marrant parce que toi
tu  tu vas pas te prendre le cul tu
vas aller
chercher tes vaches
parce que je viens de voir quelques clips tu
sais j'ai
beaucoup de trucs de moi sur la synergie comme
ramper comme je vais parler tu sais
et je viens de voir  ces deux-là
donc d'accord c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi la
question a surgi o  kay
vous vous sentez à l'aise dans cette
situation avec votre poignée
parce que vous êtes grand donc évidemment
le dribble est plus haut et ouais
protégez donc avez-vous beaucoup travaillé dessus
parce que je ouais je pense et j'ai vraiment besoin
de travailler dessus parce que
ouais  je ne suis pas un meneur de jeu naturel et je
dois travailler dur pour le garder
sous contrôle et
pour utiliser les pick and rolls, vous devez avoir
une bonne poignée de balle
parce que si oui, si vous ne pouvez pas dribbler, vous
ne pouvez pas utiliser le  écran
et vous pouvez aller sur la jante donc c'est vraiment
important d'avoir une bonne poignée de balle et
je travaille dessus
tous les jours avant après l'entraînement surtout
avant
mais oui c'est vraiment important je pense d'
accord que c'est pourquoi
euh il y avait la question  à propos des
mains euh
au début parce que parfois ça
a
une relation avec la vague
euh à propos de la défense euh je pense que c'est
le plus le plus euh le plus gros point d'
interrogation
sur votre jeu euh entrer dans la
nba
parce que tu es grand  tu as dit que tu devais
gagner en flexibilité
pour descendre et se différencier, je veux dire des
gardes plus rapides, plus rapides, combien de
positions vous pensez
pouvoir défendre en tête-à-tête en ce moment, je
veux dire que la
plupart des gars diront deux trois quatre d'
accord
deux trois pour l'instant pour le moment  quand je
deviens plus fort les quatre
mais je pense que je peux aussi défendre la
seule position parce que
comme quand je jouais à la bcl, je jouais le meneur de jeu de secours
et euh quand je suis arrivé sur le terrain,
ma première clé
était de mettre toute la pression sur le terrain
contre les
gars  c'est six un six pieds six deux
donc c'était vraiment difficile pour un gars
qui fait six dix de mettre toute la
pression de base
étant vaincu tout le temps mais je pense que
c'est vraiment ça m'a vraiment aidé
mais comme vous le voyez dans la ligue ce n'est pas
la même chose qu'en europe où
ils mettent toute la pression sur le terrain
mais je pense que je peux le faire et
je pense que quand je vieillis, je deviens plus
fort
et quand je suis au bon endroit je peux
défendre un à quatre je pense que je suis totalement d'
accord  avec ce que vous avez dit que la
flexibilité est aller  être l'un des
points clés pour vous
et le second, mais cela viendrait
avec l'expérience, je
dirais encore une fois sans offenser cela,
mais gardez simplement les pieds sur terre
comme plusieurs fois, vous savez que vous
aimez juste mordre légèrement  les faux
qui vous tuent soit lors de fermetures,
soit dans des situations
individuelles, ce sont les deux choses principales parce que pour
moi,
je reviens à la question qu'Alex
vous a posée il y a quelques minutes,
vous pouvez aller jusqu'au bout
ou avec quelqu'un à
côté  à vous à la jante je vous n'avez pas l'air
si effrayé comme gérer le
contact c'est juste une question d'
impact sur le poids corporel en ce moment comme vous
savez quand vous aurez 10 10
10 kilos de plus, vous pouvez facilement mettre l'
épaule vous savez  utilisez le contact et allez
je suis d'accord avec ça mais ça va être à
peu près la même chose avec la
flexibilité de la défense en gardant l'équilibre et
peut-être en gardant
un peu les pieds sur terre
je pense que vous pouvez le gérer comme
la vitesse latérale de ce que je '  je
regarde  ing en ce moment ne
semble pas nécessairement être un problème, surtout
si ces gars dont vous parlez
encore en
bcl ces meneurs courts ils sont
ils sont des coureurs
ils sont rapides ouais pouvez-vous mec comme ça
je veux dire
la ligue belge  est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de
joueurs qui ressemblent
aux gars comme nous dans la ligue française,
vous savez, donc je ne pense pas
que changer de défense puisse être quelque chose
si vous pouvez garder
cette mobilité, puis augmenter
un peu les latinos et
changer de flexibilité  la défense ne
va pas être un
problème aujourd'hui avec le basket moderne c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
ouais je pense que oui je pense que tu as
raison ouais
c'est ce que je voulais dire ici je sais que
tu as dit que
tu ne regardes pas beaucoup d'autres  jeux
mais
euh que pensez-vous est la chose la plus
importante
dans la défense nbs d'aujourd'hui parce qu'elle
a beaucoup évolué ces dernières années euh
quoi pensez-vous que vous devez
travailler plus
pour obtenir je pense que pour moi je pense que la
défense de l'équipe de l'équipe je  c'est le plus important
avant tout
si euh si t'es si tu défends comme une
équipe
c'est déjà fini mais pour moi euh
euh mettre ouais beaucoup de pression
apportant de l'énergie et de la défense je pense
que c'est le plus important pour
moi je pense
tout  d'accord, ce n'est pas facile que l'autre
équipe puisse gérer le ballon facilement
obtenir des regards plus faciles fait la chose la plus
importante
pensez-vous que vous avez assez d'impact de
taureau euh à partir de maintenant vous
je je vous connais vous avez plutôt bien joué la voie de dépassement
parce que vous êtes long  mais je
parle d'aider
le côté faible tu es grand tu
as sept sept sept pieds une durée de victoire
euh tu sens que tu peux être plus efficace des
deux
euh je pense que je ne peux pas vraiment bien lire la
défense
euh quand  étant un dernier homme, j'essaie d'en
nier autant que possible, mais parfois je
dois juste être là devant prendre une charge
qui sont des choses que j'ai besoin d'apprendre
davantage
et qui viendront avec le temps mais je
pense que
lire la défense je pense  je ne peux pas
vraiment le faire juste un  des petites choses
que euh
je dois être plus mature avec
toi tu as parlé euh des bons
endroits
plus tard dans ta carrière tu dis quand je suis dans
les bons endroits
euh en parlant de ton avenir euh tu t'as
dit
tu tu pourras
contribuer que pensez-vous
est votre est votre rôle euh pour les
premières années que vous passerez dans le mba
euh si je vais à la nba je veux juste euh
devenir meilleur en tant que joueur
pour améliorer autant que possible je pense
que c'est le premier  ce que je veux vraiment
faire,
c'est m'améliorer pour m'entraîner dur
et les minutes que j'obtiens ou même pas les
minutes que je n'obtiens pas
juste l'expérience que j'obtiendrai voyager
avec l'équipe
obtenir une bonne équipe obtenir un bon groupe
qui est vraiment important pour  moi
euh pour grandir en tant que personne aussi je pense
que c'est vraiment important aussi
et ouais juste essayer de s'améliorer car
ouais faire un très grand pas là
-bas et pour aller mieux et
nous sommes d'accord avec le romain sur ce
point tu dois jouer
euh comment trouvez-vous le temps de jeu
euh dans le  les premières années dans la
nba um
êtes-vous prêt à être un
joueur de draft stash pendant quelques années ou
voulez-vous
traverser l'océan cette année
euh j'espère ouais bien sûr j'espère que je peux euh
je peux rester là et travailler  avec beaucoup d'
entraîneurs qui sont vraiment
euh euh vraiment
ils sont des spécialistes dans leur truc
et qu'ils ne peuvent pas me donner autant d'
informations pour obtenir un meilleur joueur mais
ouais si si j'obtiens un draft et un
joueur de réserve et que je vais à un  bon club en
europe ce n'est pas mal c'est sûr parce que je
joue juste je veux jouer au plus haut
niveau possible
pour faire sortir la meilleure personne de moi-même et
le meilleur joueur je peux être d'
accord avec ce travail ce
travail quotidien
ce qui peut  vous dites à propos des routines que
vous avez la façon dont vous vous entraînez
que pouvez-vous dire aux gens qui ne
vous connaissent pas vraiment pour l'instant
je pense que le point le plus fort est euh
j'ai une très bonne éthique de travail
euh je pense que c'est vraiment important  pour
obtenir autant de répétitions que possible
dans votre jeu et vous améliorer  tous les jours
je veux dire ouais tout le monde dit ouais je
veux m'améliorer tous les jours mais je veux dire
la chose que tu peux faire hier c'est
important
de t'améliorer aujourd'hui dans les jours les
choses que tu fais aujourd'hui
pour t'améliorer demain et c'est vraiment
important pour  moi
de ne pas rester au même niveau et
chaque fois qu'il s'agit même de s'étirer ou d'entrer
dans la salle de gym,
recevoir des coups comme les petits
détails sont vraiment
très importants incluez-vous regarder
vos propres matchs
dans vos routines de préparation et des trucs
comme ça oh ouais pour  bien sûr à chaque fois
quand ouais avec la nationalité belge
euh parfois c'est difficile parce que euh
la façon dont tu dis la la
mauvaise qualité mais euh je toujours après le
match même après le match dans le buzz je
regarde à nouveau mes matchs des
choses que je fais mal je suis  essayer d'
améliorer cela et
je pense que c'est vraiment important
aussi de devenir un meilleur joueur
c'est une grande chose je pense que
tout le monde est un travailleur acharné
quand quand vous les écoutez
euh comment h  ow pensez-vous que vous pourrez le
prouver
aux équipes de la nba qui vous intervieweront
dans quelques semaines
euh je veux dire le prouver euh ouais pour le faire je
pense que
je le prouve aussi parce que je pense que
tu peux aller de oh  tu ne peux pas passer de
150 livres à 200 livres pour ne rien faire je pense que
tu dois être
dans le bon état d'esprit tu dois le faire
tous les jours euh
euh des choses auxquelles les gens ne pensent pas est
cette
nourriture euh sommeil repos c'est vraiment important
parce que  certains
certains gars pensent oh je si je suis
quatre heures au gymnase je vais grossir mais
tu manges mal tu ne dors pas tu ne te reposes pas
ça ne marchera pas si tu travailles
bien
et tu obtiens un  bonne nourriture bon programme
vous obtenez votre vous obtenez votre euh j'appelle ça
le
blanc d'œuf et c'est vraiment important de l'
avoir
euh entraînement invisible ouais c'est
nous aimons euh parler de psychologie
ici euh dans le métro nous pensons que c'est
vraiment important d'essayer de
évaluer un joueur euh de
quoi tu parlais la
routine
les choses que tu fais pour parier  euh
tous les jours ce qui te motive
ce qui fait ce qui
te donne envie de
sortir du lit très tôt quand tu ne veux pas
y aller
ce que tu as en tête euh ouais tout d'abord
euh
ma famille est vraiment importante pour moi et
je veux aussi faire mes preuves
mais je veux aussi le faire pour eux mais
aussi en
belgique beaucoup de gens disent ouais
tu peux le
faire reste en belgique tu n'es pas
assez bon et il y a même des gens qui
aussi  joué en première division en Belgique
et ils disent qu'à la télévision nationale ouais
tu ferais mieux de ne pas rester en Belgique et je
veux vraiment le prouver je ne peux pas le faire
et je suis assez bon pour eux donc
ça me conduit vraiment
bien  donc vous sentez que vous avez une puce sur l'
épaule et je ne le dis pas là
vous la belgique c'est ouais ouais c'est sûr c'est
sûr euh
j'ai une question sur le terrain
l'habitude des courts à domicile que vous avez euh
parce que quelques scouts qui étaient  à
tes jeux
ils ont remarqué que tu te mets parfois en colère
euh pas vraiment en colère mais toi tu gru  mble
vous
vous ne vous sentez pas vraiment heureux comment vous
sentez-vous à ce sujet
je veux dire au début de la saison je l'
avais plus que maintenant parce que
je n'ai pas vu mes jeux mais
vous vous ne comptez pas dessus et euh
je  a beaucoup parlé avec l'entraîneur et il a aussi
dit qu'il
fallait faire attention avec ça parce que parfois ça
se passe mal,
vous ne le voulez pas comme ça mais ça se passe
mal et
euh au début de la saison je l'ai
eu aux arbitres et s'ils  fait un mauvais
appel je leur
parlais mais je pense que c'est juste
parce que
tu es aussi jeune et tu dois
être plus mature dans cette partie mais je pense que
je suis vraiment en train de grandir dans ce processus
parce que comme ces derniers temps j'ai à peine  faites-le bien
parfois c'est juste dans le feu de l'action
vous jouez au jeu et je pense que
chaque joueur l'a compris
mais je pense que je m'améliore vraiment
dans cette partie
donc vous avez appris  pour surveiller
votre propre langage corporel
ouais bien sûr parce que c'est aussi très
important de rester dans le jeu et de
ne pas s'impliquer  avec le reste parce
que ce sont des choses qui vont vous sortir
du jeu et vous concentrer davantage
sur la résine du jeu et
maintenant quand j'ai quelque chose, je le
garde juste pour moi,
concentrez-vous sur le jeu et c'est le plus
important pour  juste pour gagner autant
que possible la plupart des jeux ouais parce
que plus que les arbitres,
c'est vous savez que c'est ce que vous le montrez à
l'adversaire
comme moi par exemple quand je travaille sur nos
adversaires
si je vois des joueurs qui peuvent essentiellement le
perdre ou sortir  du jeu
peut facilement être sûr qu'il y aura une
ligne à ce sujet sur le rapport de dépistage
et la première chose qui va se
passer pendant le jeu est que je vais le
dire à l'un de mes gars
parce que j'ai des gars qui savent comment  comme un
truc qui
va tout droit parce
que c'est quelque chose que
vous savez si si vous finissez par être l'un
des joueurs clés de votre équipe,
je viendrai pour ça,
c'est surtout
dans je veux dire que c'est déjà du
basket professionnel ici alors
nous  're tous comp  etitors joueurs coachs
nous sommes tous des compétiteurs et
nous voulons que vous sachiez trouver les meilleures façons
de gagner parfois c'est
oui ils ne devraient pas nettoyer mais ils le sont
mais dans la ligue
c'est comme si c'était même vous savez
plus haut et plus intense et puis c'est
comme
les combats aériens parfois donc c'est quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant comme
le fait que vous en soyez conscient est
important et ensuite travailler dessus est
important aussi
parce que moins vous montrez de faiblesses, c'est
sûr ouais
comprenez que complètement vous semblez euh
vous semblez un peu comme  un gars très confiant
euh
nous avons eu beaucoup de euh avec l'équipe du podcast
parce que vous étiez
euh vous vous disputiez à propos de votre
classement
sur notre sur notre site Web c'est vrai
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi vous êtes venu en fait
parce que
vous n'auriez pas répondu  nous
n'aurions rien dit mais tu
répondais comme
quoi d'accord allons-y parlons oui je veux dire
ouais c'était juste bien
ça juste je pense que ça fait partie du jeu
tu dois ouais
tu dois être là pour toi  toi-même et tu
dois te défendre mais
je n'aime pas être pour
quoi que ce soit
sur les réseaux sociaux parce que c'est à côté du
jeu mais
parfois tu dois te lever alors qu'est-ce que
tu as et
je pense que je pense  c'est vraiment important,
mais parce que la confiance est la chose la plus
importante au basket si
vous n'avez pas confiance, vous n'allez pas y
arriver et en
dehors du terrain, je suis un gars humble et je
ne peux pas le trouver avec tout le monde mais sur le
cour tu dois être
ouais toi même quand je joue olson mon meilleur
ami joue là
je lui parle de détritus il ne peut pas tirer
comme il ne peut pas
il ne peut pas tirer mais je dis que je ne peux pas il
ne peut pas tirer et il manque des lancers francs
et je suis ce genre de gars qui
peut vraiment être dans la tête de quelqu'un d'autre et
c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai la confiance pour
ça
qui est ton meilleur ami euh harry
va bien et joue pour austin
austin  ouais ouais
euh comment donc vous vous vous disputiez à propos
du
classement comment comment vous classez-
vous vous comparez-vous
je veux dire
euh c'est vraiment difficile de se
classer parce que je ne
regarde pas les autres joueurs donc c'est difficile de
me classer mais
je pense que j'ai le potentiel d'être en
retard premier autour du premier
deuxième tour pour un deuxième match  rond
peut
-être parce que j'ai vraiment travaillé très dur
pour ça et je pense que je le méritais à cause
de mon travail vraiment dur et je pense que
je peux grandir beaucoup plus et je ne suis pas proche
de mon
euh comment le dites-vous
ouais d'accord alors  toi tu n'as pas de
problème de
plus en plus de gens ils euh
je veux dire les jeunes joueurs ils
ne veulent parfois pas être un
choix de deuxième tour et ils préfèrent être
un
agent libre andre non repêché tu n'as
aucun problème à  être un choix de deuxième tour
eh bien je n'ai pas de problème mais je
travaille vraiment pour que ce soit
pour être un premier tour
bien sûr euh tu as un
euh qu'est-ce que tu peux apporter
l'année prochaine parce que c'est ce que les gens
vont demander
nous allons sur les rapports de scooter et des
trucs comme ça  que pensez-vous que vous
pouvez apporter à
une équipe de la nba l'année prochaine je sais que vous voulez
travailler
vous l'avez dit vous voulez travailler pour être le meilleur
joueur que vous puissiez être
mais en ce moment je pense que vous pouvez m'apporter
ma première année je pense que la plupart des choses  est
euh
d'apporter beaucoup d'énergie sur le terrain
être là en défense est aussi toujours
la première chose que vous pouvez avoir une mauvaise
nuit de tir en attaque mais
en défense vous devez toujours être là sans
excuses pour cela donc la défense sera
la plus importante  chose pour moi dans l'
équipe de la nba
et euh ouais les dauphins viendront si si
vous êtes bon en défense et que vous faites
votre truc en défense le bureau
viendra avec le courant
avez-vous une destination préférée euh cette
destination ou oh non je je ne  J'ai une
destination préférée
toi tu as grandi en tant que fan de
n'importe quelle équipe de la nba d'accord j'ai une idole
et j'aime les joueurs comme les danseurs de luca
lebron james et
ce sera bien de jouer à côté d'eux mais
je veux dire jouer dans n'importe quelle équipe de la nba que ça
croit en toi est plus important de
jouer contre ton idole non  non tu as
raison ne te mets pas en
difficulté maintenant
je n'essayais pas de te tromper
mais c'était un non ce n'est pas un truc je veux dire
dans n'importe quelle équipe de la nba qui croit en toi
c'est la chose la plus importante
si tu ressens  bien et vous pouvez grandir en tant que
joueur et vous pouvez aider une équipe à gagner
même à gagner des championnats ce sera génial
pour moi savez-vous qui quand
euh qui a envoyé un éclaireur pour euh regarder
un de vos matchs euh j'ai eu
je ne sais pas parce que  je ne suis pas vraiment occupé
avec ça parce que je me suis vraiment concentré pour essayer de
gagner le championnat cette année
mais ouais
vous dans le fond de votre esprit vous l'avez toujours
dans votre esprit mais euh je pense ouais certains
éclaireurs euh je pense
sept équipes différentes  dans deux trois semaines
donc mais je ne suis pas vraiment occupé avec eux euh
c'est mon agence qui fait tout à ce
sujet et
j'essaie juste de me concentrer sur ce
petit quiz correct les joueurs belges qui sont arrivés
à la nba
comme je veux dire dj et venga l'ont fait  mais pas
faire un brouillon
accelerafell est allé au brouillon c'était je
pense
52. denver nug  obtient je pense
mais il a de la cachette pour euh real madrid
je pense qu'il est 52 53 denver niggas ouais si
j'ai raison je ne sais pas
je je ne l'ai pas sur euh
[Musique]
ouais fais le brouillon ce sera génial
comme juste  aussi pour mettre la belgique sur
la carte et je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
potentiel en belgique
et ce sera formidable pour cela aussi parce que
nous sommes un très petit
pays et je pense que ce sera bien que vous
ayez des projets avec
l'équipe nationale et  cet été ou êtes-
vous concentré
euh cet été ce sera vraiment occupé
parce que
euh ouais notre saison se termine
quelque part commence juin euh
je vais je serai vraiment occupé avec la
vaccination
euh tu convoites et ouais et juin je
partirai probablement aux états d'
abord pour  une voie vers mon agence et puis
euh pour faire des séances d'entraînement avec des équipes
parce qu'il y en a quelques-unes alignées donc
ça va être vraiment difficile d'aller
avec l'équipe nationale
et ça me fait vraiment mal parce que j'ai
vraiment aimé toujours être avec les
équipes nationales  c'est vraiment important aussi les
jeunes  les ions sont toujours ce
qu'il y avait là
et euh ouais c'est vraiment ça craint
un peu je ne peux pas être là d'
accord les amis euh
pouvez-vous dire que c'est pour le
public anglophone
euh pouvez-vous dire votre nom parce qu'ils
ne sauront pas  comment le prononcer
donc oui je peux prononcer l'induction je
ne peux pas le prononcer en anglais c'est ce que
vous voulez
en anglais je dirai amis
blindberg je dirai que
je pense que c'est plus facile mais si vous voyez je le
dis
en néerlandais  ce seront des amis aveugles
donc c'est un peu différent d'
accord d'
accord ils t'appelleront des marques je
pense ouais
c'est le plus souvent je pense
bien merci beaucoup pour ouais pas de
problème merci
euh de m'avoir invité euh euh tous les
tous les  bonne chance pour le repêchage
merci merci à la fin de la
saison d'avant
parce que tu penses
[Musique]
bien sûr
donc
[Musique]
moi
toi